[Musique]
je vais vous raconter une histoire
histoire d'un vieil homme qui est posée
à l'entrée son village
un jeune homme arrive et lui pose cette
question bonjour monsieur comment sont
les gens dans votre village
le meilleur lui répond et toi comment
sont les gens dans ton village
le jeune homme répond dans mon village
les gens sont anxieux méchants
le vieil homme lui répond et bien tu
trouveras le même type de personnes dans
ce village
quelques heures plus tard un autre jeune
homme arrive
et pose la même question à ce vieil
homme bonjour monsieur comment sont les
gens dans votre village
le Biome lui répond et toi comment sont
les gens dans ton village
et à ce moment le jeune homme lui dit
dans mon village les gens sont gentils
accueillants bienveillants
et le VM lui répond et bien tu trouveras
le même type de personne dans ce village
pourquoi le vieil homme donne deux
réponses différentes à la même question
tout simplement parce qu'il a compris
que chacun d'entre nous porte dans son
cœur ses propres croyances on porte dans
son cœur notre propre monde
et c'est ce qui m'est arrivé pendant 29
ans pendant 29 ans
je pensais que j'étais bête je pensais
que j'étais pas intelligent
à chaque fois que j'avais une difficulté
je pensais que le problème venait de moi
quand j'ai redoublé le CP et que j'avais
des difficultés à lire et à écrire quand
en CE1 on voulait encore me faire
redoubler quand CE2 mon père a été
convoqué parce que j'avais trop de
difficultés et que je devais aller en
classe de perfectionnement
quand je vais passer mes mercredis et
mes samedis chez l'orthophoniste
également je pensais que j'étais bête
quand j'ai passé le bac et que j'ai lu
avec 10 de moyenne je faisais une seule
chose alimenter ce monstre intérieur
qu'il ne faisait que grandir grandir et
encore plus je vais alimenter de cette
croyance qui était Mohamed tu es bête et
tu n'es pas intelligent
et c'est ce qui a continué quand j'ai
fait plein de petits boulots après le
bac que j'ai repris les études pour
faire un DUT une école d'ingénieur et
que mes amis sortaient le soir le
week-end et que moi je devais aller à la
bibliothèque pour réviser et en faire
plus que les autres
et j'ai découvert à 29 ans que en vrai
il y avait des solutions et c'est de ça
que je vais vous parler aujourd'hui qui
parmi vous pense être intelligent que
lever évidemment
ah ça fait plaisir
pas mal demain
on a tous déjà entendu parler du test du
quotient intellectuel qui a été réalisé
et mis en place par Alfred Binet un
psychologue français qui a été missionné
par l'État en 1900 pour réaliser un test
afin d'aider les étudiants les enfants
en difficulté
ce test a été démocratisé au moment de
la première guerre mondiale
lorsque les Américains ont utilisé ça
avec leur soldats et tout simplement
pour savoir si les soldats étaient
intelligents ce qui avait des bons
résultats prenez des responsabilités et
ceux qui avaient des mauvais résultats
devenaient quoi de la chair à canon
et notre système scolaire le système
éducatif la société est basée sur deux
intelligences parce que le test du
quotient
intellectuel et basé sur deux
intelligences l'intelligence
logicomathématique on est bon en maths
en sciences on est logique on est carré
ou verbaux linguistique on est bon
langue à l'oral à l'écrit
et on l'a tous vécu que ce soit à
l'école ou au travail quand une personne
est forte elle est logique elle est
carrée qu'est-ce qu'il est intelligent
quand une personne s'exprime bien et qui
forte capacité en écriture qu'est-ce
qu'il est intelligent mais on dirait
rarement ça d'un sportif on dirait
rarement ça d'un artiste d'un musicien
tu as rarement une personne veut dire ah
qu'est-ce qu'il est intelligent ce
musicien
alors qu'il existe 9 types
d'intelligence ce qu'on appelle les
intelligences multiples
bien sûr il existe la première
intelligence qui est l'intelligence
logicomathématique on est bon en maths
en sciences on est logique c'est ce
qu'on retrouve souvent chez les
ingénieurs
l'intelligence verbolinguistique donc
l'appétence l'écriture à l'oral
l'expression c'est ce qu'on retrouve
chez les écrivains les avocats les
enseignants mais il reste cette haute
intelligence
on a l'intelligence kinesthésique
intelligence du corps la motricité fine
un chirurgien un horlogie mais également
un artisan fait des choses incroyables
avec ses mains et son corps
un sportif
on a l'intelligence visio-spatiale c'est
la spatialisation de la formation c'est
aussi le fait de pouvoir se retrouver
dans l'espace facilement je trouve ça
chez les architectes
on a l'intelligence musicale
on peut pas dire que Mozart n'est pas
intelligent
la musique dans les choses de quotidien
on a intelligence intrapersonnelle on
est dans l'introspection
dans la prise de décision un manager
doit développer l'intelligence 1
traditionnelle pour prendre des bonnes
décisions mais également l'intelligence
interpersonnelle
on est là dans la relation à l'autre
dans l'empathie dans la connexion avec
les autres personnes
on a l'intelligence naturaliste qui est
les appétences sur tout ce qui est en
lien avec la nature la biologie mais
également la logique parce qu'on dit que
dans la nature tout est logique et
l'intelligence existentielle c'est la
quête de sens
donc il existe 9 types d'intelligence et
on porte tous en nous c'est 9 types
d'intelligence mais dans notre quotidien
on va développer 3 à 4 intelligences
qu'on va utiliser tout le temps c'est ce
qui nous caractérise
pourquoi découvrir ces intelligences
tout simplement parce que c'est la
notice de notre cerveau
lorsqu'on monte un meuble on va d'abord
regarder la notice de ce meuble
lorsqu'on achète un téléphone on va
regarder la notice
pour savoir quelles sont les
fonctionnalités où on va regarder des
tutos mais qui a déjà regardé la notice
de notre cerveau comment nous on
fonctionne dans notre quotidien
l'intelligence c'est la capacité à
résoudre un problème et tous les jours
on a des problèmes à résoudre
ce qu'on veut apprendre une langue
étrangère
on peut bien sûr utiliser l'intelligence
verbolinguistique et répéter répéter
l'information ou sinon l'écrire mais on
peut utiliser d'autres types
d'intelligence pour répondre à la même
chose à prendre la langue étrangère
comme l'anglais on peut apprendre
l'anglais grâce à l'intelligence visio
spatiale en le mettant des images dans
ce qu'on veut apprendre en utilisant la
carte mentale le mind mapping
on peut utiliser un intelligence
kinesthésique donc en faisant des
mouvements on peut également toucher des
objets qu'on a envie d'apprendre ou
mettre des images et apprendre avec les
sensations on peut apprendre l'anglais
en utilisant l'intelligence
interpersonnelle donc la relation à
l'autre trouver des groupes de parole
faire des voyages rencontrer des
personnes qui parlent cette langue
et on peut utiliser l'intelligence
musicale pour apprendre une langue
étrangère en écoutant de la musique mais
également en mettant du rythme dans la
chose qu'on souhaite apprendre
donc au même problème on peut utiliser
différentes solutions en fonction de qui
on est
si on veut apprendre les mathématiques
bien sûr on peut être logique et
utiliser l'intelligence
logicomathématique mais également
verbolinguistique ça veut dire quoi
utiliser et les phrases des mots encore
tout à l'heure avant de venir ici je
parlais avec une maman qui me dit mon
fils a des très bonnes notes en maths ou
du moins il est très logique mais il a
un problème il comprend pas les énoncés
et donc ça problématique c'est pas qu'il
a pas d'intelligence logique aux
mathématique il doit plus travailler la
partie verbolinguistique parce qu'il
comprend pas les énoncés les problèmes
on peut apprendre les mathématiques en
utilisant l'intelligence kinesthésique
avec ce qu'on appelle les boulistes
chinois
ou l'intelligence visio-spatiale
également avec les bouliers chinois ou
même le mind mapping
et on peut apprendre des mathématiques
avec l'intelligence interpersonnelle en
allant expliquer ce qu'on a appris en
expliquant les notions en parlant
Nicolas Boileau disait ce qui se conçoit
bien c'est non c'est clairement
et les mots pour le dire arrivent tes
aimants
j'ai découvert ces intelligences à 29
ans
lorsque j'ai accepté d'aller à un
atelier de lecture rapide
j'ai accepté de faire quelque chose de
nouveau et je suis allé à cet atelier et
c'est là-bas que j'ai découvert qu'on
pouvait lire un livre de 200 pages en
moins d'une heure
et c'est là-bas que j'ai découvert que
les intelligences multiples existaient
aujourd'hui je suis viche champion du
monde de lecture rapide où j'ai lu un
livre de 170 pages en 17 minutes avec 18
sur 20 en question réponse
et pour en arriver là j'ai dû bien sûr
développer mon intelligence vers mon
linguistique
que je n'avais pas du tout aujourd'hui
je suis auteur
pour écrire un livre j'ai dû développer
mon intelligence vers bolinguistique les
intelligences se développent on n'a pas
besoin de développer toutes les
intelligences mais en fonction de nos
problématiques de l'endroit où on a
envie d'aller on va développer certaines
des intelligences on a nos intelligences
qu'on utilise tous les jours et après on
va développer d'autres intelligences
aujourd'hui je suis également triple
champion de France de Mind Mapping
ça c'est mon discours je l'ai fait en
une demi-heure avec un silo quatre
couleurs tout ce que je viens de vous
dire est là j'ai pris j'étais dans
l'avion j'ai pris une feuille un stylo 4
couleurs et j'ai fait la carte mentale
la plus simple possible avec un co4
couleur un centre le sujet des branches
des mots et quelques images
ça m'a pris une demi-heure et là pendant
que je vous parle je vois exactement où
j'en suis dans mon discours je n'ai pas
besoin de me tourner je sais que je suis
en haut à gauche
et ça c'est une carte mentale un peu
plus développée parce que aujourd'hui je
suis triple champion de France de
manière ping et j'enseigne cela et là ça
a pris un peu plus de temps c'était au
championnat de France j'avais un
magazine de 70 pages je devais lire en
moins de deux heures et le résumer sous
forme de carte mentale donc l'épreuve
c'est deux heures pour lire un magazine
de 70 pages et le résumé sous forme de
carte mentale et ça c'est le résumé que
j'ai fait en deux heures avec la lecture
mais ce qui est fort dans la carte
mentale c'est que ça utilise 7 des 9
intelligences et c'est pour ça que ça
fonctionne autant le bindapping est
démocratisé en parlant depuis les années
2000 dans quasiment toutes les écoles
ça utilise tout simplement
l'intelligence vertbaud linguistique
parce qu'il faut mettre des mots et
synthétiser l'information et ça utilise
l'intelligence
logicomathématique parce que faut être
logique il faut structurer notre
discours et structurer nos notes ça
utilise l'intelligence kinesthésique
parce qu'il faut écrire dessiner ça
utilise l'intelligence visio-spatiale
faut se spécialiser l'information
en haut en haut à droite en bas à gauche
ça utilise l'intelligence
intra-impersonnelle parce qu'on se pose
des questions sur ce qu'on va écrire
on est en introspection mais également
l'intelligence interpersonnelle regardez
je suis en train de vous parler de mon
discours uniquement grâce à la carte
mentale et l'intelligence existentielle
c'est tout simplement la quête de sens
il y a également les techniques de
mémorisation qui utilisent la totalité
de ces intelligences
quand les gens me disent je suis pas
intelligent je leur dis que c'est faux
nous sommes tous intelligents c'est
juste que certains ne développent pas
leur intelligence c'est comme si un
sportif qui allait à la salle de sport
faisait une seule séance et venez dire
ah ben moi j'ai pas de muscle
combien de fois tu t'es entraîné une
seule fois comme toutes les personnes
qui prennent des résolutions le 1er
janvier bon à la salle de sport pour
maigrir et qui le 2 arrête d'aller à la
salle de sport ils disent ben moi les
régimes ça fonctionne pas j'arrive pas à
perdre 2 points
combien de fois tu t'es entraîné et ben
c'est la même chose avec notre cerveau
le cerveau n'est pas un muscle mais plus
on va l'entraîner plus il va se muscler
et puis il va être capable de résoudre
les problématiques j'avais écouté cette
croyance au fond de moi j'aurais jamais
j'aurais jamais devenu vie champion du
monde de lecture rapide parce que de
base je suis pas un lecteur
j'aimerais finir ce discours avec deux
éléments le premier c'est ce que Albert
Einstein disait
nous sommes tous des génies
mais si vous demandez à un poisson
de grimper un arbre
il passera toute sa vie à penser qu'il
est stupide
et la deuxième chose c'est ce que je
fais régulièrement avec mes élèves c'est
vrai que tout le monde fasse ça comme
moi tous
et c'est simple je vais dire je suis et
où vous allez dire illimité et
j'aimerais que toute la salle le dise le
plus fort possible et que même les
salles d'à côté viennent nous voir et
dit mais qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est
quoi ce titre vous êtes prêts
je suis illimité merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]